Dwayne Johnson AKA The Rock is probably
one of the last people you'd imagine as
Willie Wonka but believe it or not he
almost played the role in an Instagram
post Johnson recalled being considered
by director Tim Burton for the leading
role in his 2005 remake Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory it's clear based on
his post that he was definitely
interested in the role of course though
It ultimately went to Johnny Depp
Johnson wrote quote the fact that Tim
even considered me I'll be I'm sure he
considered for all of 7 Seconds sure
meant a hell of a lot to me as I was
just breaking into the business with no
idea what the future had in store it
definitely would have been surprising to
see such a buff version of wily Wonka
and it sounds like it worked out for the
best but we'll admit we're pretty
freaked out by seeing the rock with hair